après une valse-hésitation ponctuée de
manifestations et de contestation
judiciaire le gouvernement ford
finalement rendu public le contenu du
cours d'éducation sexuelle qui sera
bientôt donner aux jeunes élèves
ontariens à peu de choses près ce
programme est le même que celui présenté
auparavant par les libéraux on prévoit
entre autres une formation sur
l'orientation sexuelle sur le
harcèlement en ligne
le sexe oral et anal l'abstinence et
l'identité de genre
l'orientation sexuelle c'est une
attraction dans l'ensemble ce programme
ressemble à celui du québec qui a été
lui aussi l'objet de pas mal de
controverses
la grande différence c'est la question
du consentement des parents au québec
sauf exception et ne se pose même pas
découvrons est obligatoire
en ontario c'est une autre affaire les
parents devront être prévenu par écrit
avant une leçon ils pourront retirer
leurs enfants de la classe s'ils
remplissent un formulaire à cet effet le
nouveau cours d'éducation sexuelle sera
offert dès la rentrée en ontario c'est
très rapide surtout si on se fie à
l'expérience québécoise ou un an plus
tard beaucoup de professeurs se disent
toujours mal à l'aise et surtout mal
outillés pour aborder cette matière
délicate
ça devrait se faire partout on sait pas
comment les commissions scolaires vont
le gérer
et s'ils vont trouver le personnel pour
nous appuyer simon vont le financement
pour le faire et si on du financement
pour envoyer les gens qui ne l'ont
jamais fait se former le gouvernement
conservateur devrait aussi trouver le
moyen de satisfaire ses propres
supporteurs qui lui reproche aujourd'hui
d'avoir accepté ce programme qu'il avait
promis de mettre aux poubelles
durant la campagne électorale ici nos
membres ont d'un radio canada montréal